[Music]
I'm Matt I'm Fergus this week we are
gonna be trying a new beard regimen mr.
Flamm this is one of the best reviewed
kind of beard kits on Amazon we both
have been matched trying you had a beard
for how long it was probably about four
years now I've had a message for five I
don't use anything because I don't know
anything about beards I'm itching all
the time my face is dry all the time oh
yeah so what are we looking for out of
this kit so we want full full not dry
not dry and just comfortable we're gonna
be doing this for one whole week and
you're gonna watch us grow the best
beards you've ever seen good morning
it's day one I'm very excited about it
I'm about to unbox the beer kit if we're
I'll see what we got and hopefully by
the end of this week this beauty will be
more luxurious let's take a look at that
box we open it up Bjorn a little we got
the beard balm so you get a little brush
then you get a little set you know case
you're traveling you got a custom call
which is cool and then some nice sharp
scissors you gotta have them sharp for
the fine-tuning let's get to it we're
gonna start with the beard oil always
stuff like this I typically just like to
drop it
throughout then you're supposed to do
the beard balm
that's a tough consistency there really
hoping that this is the thing that'll
keep my face nice and soft all day I
think now it would make sense to go
ahead and comb this out okay I'm off to
a great start so today was the first
official day of the beard balm and I
noticed that it definitely did make my
face feel less dry basically I didn't
notice my beard as much and that's kind
of a big thing what's going on good
morning everybody this is day 3 I really
like the beer pomade stuff I'm excited
to see where we go from here
[Music]
so far things have been cool I'm not
quite sure though if my beard is growing
I do like the beer ball but I did have
to stop using the oil because it was
irritating my skin okay here's an actual
real gripe that I have with the beer oil
it makes my beard oily it just looks wet
on this wetness and this shine lasts
quite a while I feel like it's kind of
Donal of some I feel like it might be
getting a little bit longer
oh no I'm kind of into it I'm here with
my lovely girlfriend have you noticed a
difference in the beard ness of it all
definitely this is the fastest I think
I've ever seen your beard that's what
are you thinking like it looks different
yeah thicker the other day I said what
do you think of the beard and what did
you say okay what y'all think y'all
think it's working oh yeah that's hot
it's working mr. Babur y'all shorts that
oh no the brows say is work hi this is
day seven of using the rapid beard it's
been a pretty cool week definitely by
far my favorite part was this premium
premium beer bomb
I mean all in all if somebody asks me
when I use it again what did it grow I
don't know
okay so I have an interesting
development here obviously I don't have
a beard anymore I shaved it off you can
tell that but what's interesting to me
before the beard oil this side of my
moustache was always a little bit
thinner than this side
he appears the beard oil actually made
this side thicker and fuller it's that
crazy it seems crazy but it looks good
and so honestly I think I'm gonna keep
using the beard oil on my mustache I'm
excited
[Music]